we talked with mike breen last week um
the
kirk gowdy award winner at the
basketball hall of fame
um also our friend mike wilbon
received that award this weekend as well
the man who
took it home in 2019 from the new york
times mark stein here on the rich eisen
show how are you doing mark
still don't believe it till somebody
says it
i bet right hall of famer mark stein of
the new york times how about that
for a resume line what was this weekend
like mark
watching uh everything that went down at
the naismith
hall of fame i think i was like
everybody i was a puddle
um i was really looking forward to this
class uh selfishly really shouldn't
try to make it about me but with this
group it's hard not to
because i basically started
right before garnett kobe
and duncan all started so i covered
their whole careers
and uh i covered kevin garnett's first
exhibition game i was a laker beat
writer
when kobe came to the lakers and he was
the first
guy that i was ever 10 years older than
i was 27 and he was 17 when he got there
and then i moved to texas the year the
spurs got duncan so
uh obviously uh you know
the coat you know with kobe it was
it was going to be momentous but also
really difficult and you know i'm
i'm just like everybody else just
watched vanessa bryant with absolute
admiration astonishment amazement just
a tower of strength no idea how she
how she pulled that off honestly she was
she was incredible as everybody i think
everybody came away saying the same
thing
and you know and i was really curious
also to see what duncan would be like up
there because he
he was so guarded and never let us in
and that was a very emotional speech and
you know they
they had the camera on top but you know
a couple feet
over from pop they you know i don't know
if people picked up on it but r.c
buford the architect of all those spurs
championship teams was
you know wiping his eyes and tears i
mean it was it was
it was a very very moving night with you
know
it was somber too it was just it was
just just an induction ceremony unlike
we've really probably ever seen
yeah i know mark i was saying before you
you called in that i i still cannot
believe
you know that kobe's not here that it
was
posthumous and jordan standing there in
that silver
and black um suit um
looked like a tuxedo in a way behind
vanessa bryant his widow
uh in laker purple
standing there and as you said you know
can't believe how she's gotten through
it that's
you could basically say that you know
pretty much every day of the year
um since the day kobe and her daughter
went down in that helicopter with so
many other young people
i i i i still cannot believe it
mark truly yeah stephen curry said the
same thing the other day too
you know i think fans
us as observers their peers you know
people close
you know no one can you know it's been
16 months but it just
it just doesn't seem possible in a lot
of ways
you know he he seemed indestructible i
mean it was part of his on-court image
you know i mean i
you know i've told the story before and
you know maybe you guys have already
heard it but you know gary vee
told this story often about you know
when kobe tours achilles
and you know when vd got to the court
and told kobe i mean i'm you know gary
veedy had done that job for
a zillion years he knew he knew what it
was and kobe said can you tape it
no kobe you can't tape it you can't tape
a torn achilles that was his
you know he he played through every
injury possible
that was the only one he couldn't and uh
you know
so i think that just kind of feeds into
the image that we have that
you know nothing could stop him mark
stein here
on the rich eisen show the 2019 kurt
gowdy
award media award winner and new york
times
reporter right here on the rich eisen
show what is the sense going into this
week about the play-in
tournament mark cause you know i i
understand wednesday night is going to
be a tremendous
contest i will definitely have my
popcorn ready for
steph um and the lakers warriors and
lakers but that means the loser
is actually gonna have to play a game
friday night with their season on the
line and i
know that that might be fan interest but
the rest of the league is sitting around
and waiting to start the playoffs so the
grizzlies spurs
pacers hornets only one team above 500
is a shot
to play in and one of the best players
in the league is certainly in terms of
fan interest mike
is definitely going to have their season
on the line friday night what do you
what do you think now that we not
know the names and players that are
involved in this tournament that it's
going down with the nba mark
i love it i think it's been a huge boost
to what was a tremendously difficult
and oftentimes dispiriting season to me
it was the best part
of a really tough season now you've been
in the network game longer than me and
i'm sure you probably know some of these
network bigwigs who if the lakers or
warriors
exit in the playing round and don't even
make the playoffs yes some some
some tv people and some league office
people are going to be
shaken by that no question but these are
weird circumstances with the lakers the
lakers are only in seventh because
lebron and a.d missed you know 40 games
combined or
whatever you know 50 whatever the number
was i mean you know
injury injuries obviously changed the
trajectory of their season but the net
positive
of the plan look the nba and really all
north american sports suffer from this
there are too many games
that are meaningless and you know
yes i'm an international soccer fan but
you know promotion and relegation is
fantastic it makes
almost every game matter it's very rare
in
in soccer leagues abroad that games are
meaningless because they have promotion
and relegation well the plan tournament
really
brought some elements of that into the
nba
and you saw games matter really all the
way up until the end
tanking is not gone obviously anyone
who's
seen what's gone on with the thunder
know they've been playing for grab
position for weeks now but
but for the most part games mattered
more
in this regular season than they than
they ever have
because there's a desperation now to get
up to six and not
fall to number seven and not be dragged
into this plan thing and it just
it makes the regular season so much
better
and the nba probably needs that more
than any other sport because of load
management
so often ours aren't playing and that
really turns people off
so yes if the lakers are warriors if you
know if they
lose early okay that's going to be some
level of a ratings catastrophe
but to me i i don't see how you look at
this and not say
it has improved the regular season
dramatically
and then you know the playoffs begin
after that writ large is where
as we're used to it and uh so even if
say some of those series start slowly
because a team
that did um comment the end of the
regular season
on fire starts out slowly because they
sat around for a week potentially even
though that might not be the exact
reason or cause
this plan is here to stay you think this
is this is not a one and done regardless
of what does
happen with the results we've already
seen enough of a result of
not uh tanking despite some
small amounts that this is here to stay
mark stein
it's got to be voted in and so look
depending on what happens
you know will there be maybe a little
bit of opposition to it i suppose
some i mean it was a uni it was
unanimously approved
coming into this season maybe it won't
be unanimous but yes i do think
it's going to get voted in because you
look lakers warriors is going to be a
ratings bonanza
and whoever loses that game has to play
one more game and that second game will
literally be
a one and done ncaa tournament style
game
those games are gonna bring good ratings
it's going to be
some semblance of a revenue infusion for
the league
and i think most teams
they they love the idea of getting that
week off yes there's you know there is
there is always the rest versus rough
debate
that always happens when a team has a
week off and then has to play a playoff
game and we see that sometimes
in later rounds when a team finishes a
season early but like look at the net
the nets traded for james harden in
january with no training camp they now
get to
replicate a little bit they get to have
a mini camp for the next five six days
they're not practicing today but they're
gonna
they're gonna have a decent week of
practices which they really haven't had
because nobody practiced this season so
again i just i just think many more
positives it's not flawless
it is not eradicated tanking completely
but we talked a lot more about the
seedings and the races
than we did about tanking at the end of
the regular season and nothing was
decided really
until the last day so i mean to me those
those are huge positives
for the regular season it used to just
be all we talked about was mvp that was
it that was all the regular season was
good for 82 games of mvp
talk and satisfying regional tv
contracts and i think the last month of
this season
after a really rocky start and all the
postponements and all the covered stuff
the last month of the season was was
pretty dang good
mark stein new york times nba columnist
as well right here on the rich eisen
show
so what's the story we're not talking
about going into
uh the playoffs what what intrigues you
what fascinates you
about certainly the 12 teams that we
know
are making it so far what do you got for
me on that well
we're you know we're focused on the play
in now but that that focus
will swiftly shift to brooklyn now the
lakers
you know the lakers are seated seventh
and they've got two you know
which means they have two home games to
win one they're going to win at least
one they're going to be in the playoffs
they're going to be the scariest
number season number seven seed ever and
people are gonna pick
and i will pick them to beat phoenix too
um
so i i think i think my interest will
shift really more to
how scary does brooklyn look and last
night i'm sure you guys have seen the
the highlights of you know doing a
globetrotters routine yes
like blake griffin the mike james off
the board to kd
i mean it was ridiculous they're they're
frightening but
honestly milwaukee fascinates me because
miami wanted them miami happily slid to
six
and you know milwaukee has they brought
in drew holiday
they have a very expensive three-man
corn now giannis
true holiday middleton they've got
billions they got rich eyes and money
invested in these
three guys nice and they've got to get
through
miami probably the net and probably
philly
just to get just to get to the finals
just to get to whoever
wins the west that is that is not going
to be a fun ride for them
for the milwaukee bucks mark i respect
you and your reporting skills but i'm
glad you're not a financial reporter
mark
i'd have to ask you to check your
sources on what you just said yeah math
math is not my strong suit the apology
yeah stay away from paul krugman
basically what i'm saying inside your
building that's basically what i'm
saying
um so uh let's talk about
what you just said about the lakers why
i mean if lebron says he's never going
to be 100
again and you know um
los angeles hasn't had a several it's
been a long time since they were all
healthy and ready to go and
what makes you think lebron's back and
now they'll get through one of these two
games and win one of these at home and
and and take out the suns what what
makes you say that
because i just look i'm i'm i i have all
the same questions
and concerns you do we you know we we
those guys have not been able to stay
healthy
and you know i wrote this in early april
and people thought i was an alien
then and i said it then this you know
people it is a
huge mistake to think a.d and lebron
come back
and it's just very linear and the lakers
are back to where they were the injuries
a d
and lebron suffered are so severe
that you do fear recurrence and even
last night
lebron had a tweet that had everybody
unnerved
late in that game when not really clear
why he was even in the game but
but the reality is even saying all that
with all the skepticism
i mean are who are you gonna pick the
phoenix suns with no playoff experience
as great as they were in this regular
season
and chris paul's an mvp candidate now
but beyond chris paul and jay crowder
they have no playoff experience on that
team are you gonna pick them to beat the
lakers i mean
i i think we've all you know who do
you know anyone who's a pundit and does
predictions for a living like you you
just know in the nba picking against
lebron james is not a
not a wise idea so i don't know that
he's going to be fine i certainly think
they're going to have enough to get
through
a play-in game but you know are there
going to be setbacks in the playoffs for
a.d
and lebron health-wise there certainly
could be but even
fearing that i'm still against against
phoenix i will still
i guess i don't i guess i'm soft i don't
have the guts to pick against
pick against the lakers and how about
here in l.a what if playoff p does in
fact show up
and the kawhi that you know for some
reason did not show up in the bubble
up 3-1 uh that guy that we saw
in the in the playoffs in his previous
seasons before joining the clippers what
if they show up
they're a four-seed they're just like
nobody's talking about him literally
nobody appears to be talking about the
clippers because of that bright shiny
object that's their
cotenant here in los angeles what do you
think about them
i'm just wondering what's under the
radar this weekend and the talk was did
you notice how the clippers found a way
to lose to houston and okc back to back
they wanted that four seed they want to
avoid the lakers that's that what you're
saying
completely out of the lakers bracket
until the conference finals and
you know jared dudley said it post game
last night i think he's exactly right
teams should want the lakers earlier
than later if you've got a place if the
lakers are in the conference finals by
then they've got a head of steam and
they're a bigger problem
i agree with them but look the clippers
are better
and it's funny because rondo
made so little impact in atlanta the
hawks signed him to a two-year
15 million dollar deal he really did
nothing
in atlanta but i would say respect
within the lakers for rondo is such that
they think just his presence
is going to make them a tougher better
team and you know we know all about
playoff rondo and how much better he is
in the postseason so
i'll actually be watching that series
because i live in dallas and the
clippers
you know got their way they they
maneuvered their way to number four
they'll play dallas
again so that's actually a series that
i'll be watching closely
but you're right i mean no but nobody
after last season nobody really expects
anything
i mean the clippers are gonna the
clippers are approved to us team just
like milwaukee
nobody's going to go out on a limb
picking the clippers until they show us
that they've
learned lessons from what happened in
the bubble before i let you go mark
stein
um i will ask you the question that you
said was the he used to be the only
thing
that was discussed over an 82 game arc
of a regular season and that is who is
the mvp who is your
most valuable player of 2020 20 21
i am not an official voter and not so i
have the my
ballots were due either last night or
this morning so i did not turn in an
official ballot
i'm actually doing it tomorrow in my
weekly newsletter so i'm
going to arrive at my final decision at
some point tonight i have to say i've
been a jokic guy for a long time
but what stephen curry did has me has me
thinking has not i you know there the
case for steph
is what he did you know winning a
scoring title at his at his at this
stage in his career only jordan has done
it
at this stage his career and the
warriors
if you extrapolated over 82 games
they're only a 44 win team
and westbrook is the only mvp we've seen
in this league
since moses you know he was the first
since moses in 81 82
to come from a non 50 win team but that
thunder team won
47 and and russ averaged a triple double
so they were in the neighborhood of 50
the warriors were not close to 50 wins
but i'm telling you i mean you you've
seen
you know lebron said it john murray said
it the the player chad
i think if the players vote for mvp they
will vote for steph
and jokic had an incredible season in
denver
and kept that king's team together after
jamal murray
to me it's one or the other and you know
what the problem with mvp the problem
with all the awards this year but mvp
mvp is so deep there are five spots on
the ballot and someone like luca
who averaged you know what twenty eight
eight and eight i don't think he can get
a top five spot
i mean that's how competitive it is with
chris paul and embiid and jokic and
steph and giannis
and you know julius randle will be in
the top five on some ballots
i mean it's a it is a there are a long
list of candidates but
i i'm i'm yolk at your steps and i'm
figuring it out tonight that's my best
answer well in terms of steph i mean if
you're going to say with yogurt she kept
the team together
um without jamal murray i mean steph
knew coming into the season that klay
thompson wasn't there
and you know i i i would i would vote
for
for steph as well i guess my parting
question for you is how dangerous are
the warriors
what do you think what do you think
about them
because you know draymond essentially
this week you know even though
uh steph did pay homage to baron davis
in the we believe warriors
you know draymond last week didn't want
to hear that because they have steph
frickin curry to
clean it up what he had to say and that
they're not we believe 2.0 that they're
they're champions they
they they have a championship pedigree
for good reason
uh-huh their role players are coming
around they have picked it up really i
mean they finished the season with a
six-game winning streak so i
look utah is another one of those teams
that nobody talks about right they had a
dominant regular season
and i do i look the lakers i
i think the lakers beat the warriors in
the first playing game but i'm picking
the warriors against memphis or san
antonio
whoever they've got to be to get in and
you're right utah does not want to see
you don't want to see stephen curry in a
seven game series they they will
there is already a lot of pressure on
utah
to live up to what they did in the
regular season and people don't regard
them
as a legitimate title threat so there
there's already pressure on that team
and it won't be fun for them to have to
deal
with with steph and curry but i mean the
jazz are a great defensive team they got
a lot of shooters that they should not
be losing a series
to the golden state warriors but can can
steph make their life miserable take
that thing
six or seven and and get people in salt
lake city very nervous yes
he can mark thanks for the call
appreciate it look for my calder in the
playoffs i'd love to continue this to be
continued
if you will um with uh with games being
played
thanks again i appreciate your insight
all good good to talk to you you bet
that's mark stein at the steinline
on twitter i follow him you should too
at the steinline
on twitter and instagram some incredible
insight
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here